Tina Brown transform Vanity Fair into a
legendary and provocative track of pop
culture the former editor-in-chief was
brought in to lead the magazine back in
1983 after it failed to find its voice
and struggled to gain advertisers her
first cover take a look at this Blonde
Ambition featuring actress Daryl Hannah
made an edgy statement you could say
about the publication's future it was
followed by other iconic images
including Madonna Michael Jackson Eddie
Murphy and Cher Browns first memoir the
vanity fair' Diaries pulls back the
cover of her time as editor-in-chief of
the magazine she's published her own
diary entries from 1983 to 1992 Tina
Brown welcome to the table this is juicy
juicy gossipy dishing for sexy and smart
finally opening those pages you really
did but I think it's interesting that
you talk about your life Tina when you
were in school you got kicked out of
three different high schools true as a
kid and your father your father blames
the high school for failing this very
unusual girl yeah that was what was so
great about my father he was so proud of
having a disrupter as a daughter yes yes
very early yeah he would go in and he
would say how sad it must be if you'd
have failed with this extraordinary girl
their heads held high they would sweep
out go done let's go darling like pack
your trunk and let's go but here you
arrived in New York your very first day
you're not yet 30 and in the cab on the
way to your hotel you hear Ruth Browne
dr. Ruth giving very explicit sexual
directions sexual very graphic sexual
act and you're thinking what have I
gotten myself into you come out of the
country it's on the radio I'm bumping
along you know in the cab from JFK with
my you know case in the back knowing I'm
gonna be going into this editorial
challenge and suddenly there's a rasping
voice as I'm looking out the window and
I'm thinking what is this place you know
what do they do what what are you
listening to you know I think you said
my kind of town that's really the point
you ever wanted to come to New York was
New York was for me having coming from
London it was the capital of the action
and you know I'm a girl of the arena you
know I like to be in that gladiatorial
ring and if you've been in London for
four years editing as I had
that was exciting but nothing like you
know being on Broadway which is what I
felt that being in New York City
characterized yeah did he describe that
moment to I mean when you decided you
wanted to move from being a writer to an
editor you were assigned a story about
go-go dancers right I was I mean it was
really at that moment because they asked
if I would dance as a go-go dancer to
get a sense of you know like Gloria
Steinem when it worked as a bunny and
did you I did I was Union Jackie
actually me and when I got off that
dancing I I thought to myself I think
it's time I made the assignments you
know I want to be the one to actually
tell people what it's no more of this
but when you stand at a table do you
think I need to hop up there you weren't
thirty yet that's what's so amazing you
take over Vanity Fair just as you're
turning 30 that's extraordinary
yeah it seems young now you know I was
this kind of I blazed ahead as a kind of
a young took you know I had I had had
four and a half years of editing the
Tattler in London and it had been very
successful so that was my sort of
learning curve you know and when I came
to Vanity Fair I really had a strong
vision of what I wanted to what was that
it was a sophisticated mix I felt that
American magazines were not combining
literature with celebrity with arts with
business you know that I saw it as this
kind of gleaming package that was on the
front edge of culture and that was all
about how that would all mix together so
it was always about the search for the
mix you know the movie star piece the
crime piece the famous for the covers -
yes what did they do for you and what
was the one that launched it well the
covers were absolutely critical and the
first cover immediately made a statement
the one you sprayed with with the barrel
hand with him because it actually
followed the first you know failed
editions which were very sort of
pretentious and and and sort of arty
illustrations I wanted to immediately
say this is glamorous this is edgy which
of course the line traded helmut
newton's wonderful picture then the
Reagan's the Reagan's were a critical
cover for us we got access to shoot them
at the White House we went to do that
and I took with me Harry Benson the
great photographer he was such a
brilliant you know mischievous mind he
brought with him a boom box and in the
boom box was a tape of Franklin
Archer singing Nazi with the laughing
face as the Reagan's walked in he puts
on the boombox and Nancy says well let's
dance darling I love her she kicked the
perfect but if she hadn't liked the
pictures she asked you to come you had
to go to the White House and show her
those pictures I did if she didn't like
him you wouldn't because when they
kissed I knew I had but you know a
spread of a lifetime went back to the
office was busy laying it out suddenly
get the call mrs. Reagan needs to
approve the pictures but first I just
hid and then sign new house the chairman
said you have to show Nancy Reagan the
pictures send them I thought I'm not
sending them I hopped onto the Trent of
the plane took the shuttle down there
and sat there for like three hours in
the antechamber and finally persuaded
them to run this is a story about Condon
s as well talk about sign Newhouse and
Alexander Lieberman yeah well sign your
house was the small quirky very shy
Roman Emperor if you're - whose company
it was so he was he was the only really
person that mattered but he was also a
very reluctant sort of power chief in a
sense which is what made him very
beguiling had a strong instinct very
mercurial but he really knew what he
wanted and he appreciated editors
appreciated magazines
Alexander Lieberman his editorial
director was this very very cultured a
great artist himself knew everybody from
sort of Picasso to you know Diana
Vreeland
he was the cut the culture the style you
know the editorial taste my dear you
know he had this little moustache of
Douglas Fairbanks moustache and the two
of them had this dynamic way you have to
somehow negotiate the politics between
them they've never seen anybody like you
what's the German scene of a new a new
editor Radhika Jones well I think it's a
completely different company now it was
a much more personal company them
because sign new house was so personally
involved with magazines and that at
Oriel director Alex as of course gone
it's more of a corporation now but they
have Anna Wintour who's you know a
fabulous editorial director who is there
and David Remnick of course at The New
Yorker so they are the sort of guiding
spirits now of Conde Nast and I think
Radhika Jones will be a terrific choice
she's young you know which I like
she's very literary she has intellectual
rigour and I think she's going to bring
her new broom actually to the whole
situation you bring a new
my Tina Brown thank you so much thank
you and the Vanity Fair Diaries is on
sale today